bonjour jean claude beaujour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin dans la matinale rc france alors
on a vu un les déclarations les mises en
garde même plutôt de joe biden à l'égard
de vladimir poutine on connaissait ses
relations on l'a vu avec l'ancien
président américain
ce ne sont pas du tout les mêmes hommes
à quoi s'attendre selon vous pour cette
rencontre entre le chef du kremlin et
joe biden ce ne sont pas les mêmes
sommes parce qu'à la fois du côté de de
vladimir poutine on sait qu'il a une
vision une doctrine d'une russie forte
bien éloignée de la russie de la
fédération de russie des années au
milieu des années 80 90 à l'époque où
les états unis faisait un petit peu
l'agenda du côté du côté démocrate joe
biden connaît très bien la russie
connais très bien
l'est de la russie il a beaucoup voyagé
c'est un spécialiste des questions
internationales et donc on voit bien que
ce sont deux visions complètement
différentes qui qui s'affrontent en
sachant que joe madden est habitué à la
politique internationale est habitué à
la relation avec la russie
une chose qui est certaine c'est
qu'aujourd'hui plus que jamais la russie
marquent bien le fait que elle elle
définit son espace de sécurité n'ont pas
la lumière du territoire de la
fédération de russie mais aux frontières
de l'ex urss donc elle s'affirme à la
fois comme un joueur international
elle n'a peut-être pas les moyens
économiques que les états unis mais elle
sait qu'elle a un pouvoir de nuisance
elle sait qu'elle a l'arme nucléaire et
donc quel bois elle entend désormais
compter sur la scène internationale et
ne veut pas laisser le sol des déchets à
la chine et aux états unis donc joe
biden droit affronte un président
déterminé
de l'autre côté le président démocrate a
au menu et aura au menu pour la
rencontre à la vie à la grange
aujourd'hui à la fois la question de la
sécurité
la question de la crimée la question de
la syrie la question de l'iran vous
voyez bien que et surtout la question de
la cybersécurité vous rappeliez dans
votre dans le reportage précédent qui
lie
eu ce fameux quoique puisqu'il y avait
un rapport le rapport muller avait fait
ressortir que lui est que quelques que
la russie était directement intervenu
dans les élections américaines de 2016
et qu'elle l'aurait probablement fait
dans les directions de ville 20 on voit
bien que les états unis sont en quelque
sorte de remonter donc le discours en
tout cas la rencontre sera musclé il du
côté russe on ne s'y est pas trompé
puisque monsieur ouchakov qui le
conseiller pour les affaires étrangères
de du président poutine a déjà dit qu'il
s'agissait d'une rencontre avec un
optimisme pratique mais n'est très
faible une première rencontre dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles donc
il faudra attendre et vous voyez bien
que les quatre heures de rendez vous de
réunions d'équipé en quelque sorte et
non un simple tête à tête seront
véritablement 4h pas inutile parce que
le nombre de sujets abordés le nombre
était particulièrement important parlons
des hommes de deux présidents le
président d'ovh hayden face à vladimir
poutine pour qui ce n'est pas une
première il en a rencontré beaucoup des
présidents américains vladimir poutine
parlons de leur caractère on sait
qu'avec donald trump le courant passait
plutôt plutôt bien qu'on est il avec joe
biden qu'il a d'ailleurs déjà rencontré
lorsqu'il était vice-président alors une
différence différence notable avec avec
le le président antoine c'est que
président trump était le président de
caen plus à droite
le conservateur qui correspond beaucoup
plus à la doctrine à la doctrine poutine
et donc on ne te pendre 9 pts on ne
s'étonne pas que le président russe
poutine déclare qu'il en quelque sorte
qu'il se sentait plus à l'aise avec
donald trump
du côté américain on sait qu'il y a une
équipe autour du président by day qui
est beaucoup plus beaucoup moins ouverte
à 7 cette main tendue très souple
qu'avaient les républiques et en tout
cas pas à l'est républicain dans leur
globalité mais le président trump à
l'égard de deux de platini routine dont
oui ce sont deux personnalités qui
s'affrontent mais le président baden a
aussi une expérience internationale je
disais à l'instant et il revient du
sommet de l'otan
donc on voit bien que techniquement le
président byden semble qu'on dira plus
plus plus prête à cette relation qui
sera profonde mais qui sera en six
points par quoi et puis surtout une
président biden a rappelé que la
question des droits de l'homme n'était
pas une question inutile aujourd'hui
pour l'amérique
donc voyez ce sont deux approches
véritablement différente on a une
changement de doctrine amis du côté
américain qui n'entrent pas ou qu'ils
aient moins conformes à ce que le
président poutine aurait pu plus
attendre et néanmoins le président
bailon a conscience malgré ces mises en
garde a conscience qu'il faut discuter
avec la dmr poutine mais madame soutirer
et et vos téléspectateurs comprendront
vous avez le choix entre deux choses sur
la scène internationale où vous aller à
l'affrontement et c'est la guerre et
personne ne le souhaite la guerre et
peut-être l'économie qu'elle peut être
militaire et personne ne soit je
rappelle que ce sont deux puissances
nucléaires ou et ça a toujours été comme
ça dans l'histoire d'un diplomatie vous
recherchez une solution donc c'est la
guerre ou la recherche de la solution je
pense que chacun d'entre nous conviendra
qu'il vaut mieux tout faire pour pouvoir
rechercher des solutions éviter que
qu'il y ait ces ingérences multiples et
variées en tout cas faire en sorte que
les tensions puisse s'apaiser et ce qui
pourrait sortir de cette rencontre c'est
notamment et une votre jeu vous
correspondant de rappeler c'est qu'il
n'y ait pas donc deux reprises parce
qu'il n'y a pas de rupture il n'y a pas
eu de rupture des relations
diplomatiques les ambassadeurs des deux
pays avaient et simplement été rappelés
mais qu'ils soient renvoyés à mosport à
moscou pour l'année à washington pour
l'autre respectivement à l'issue de ce
de cette rencontre ça serait déjà une
première
mais je pense que la situation ne les
rapports entre la russie et les etats
unis sont les plus mauvaises en quelque
sorte que l'on ait eu depuis le milieu
des années 80 est donc maintenant il ya
encore un long chemin à faire mais ça
serait un bon début qu'il y ait un
renvoi des ambassadeurs pour pouvoir
reprendre la coopération en tout cas le
dialogue franco russe ce week-end nous
franco-américain américano-russes même
merci beaucoup jean-claude beaujour
merci pour ce décryptage à quelques
heures de la rencontre entre joe biden
et vladimir poutine ce matin en direct
sur notre antenne